à ma droite va nous annoncer mm à gauche
nous avons maxence je vous frapperai
aussi visité des bêtes âgées horrible à
celle entre oui c'est long c'est cool je
ne dis plus bonjour tu as bien raison et
bien bonjour à tous je dis bonjour ça va
mieux bonjour bonjour ça va au nom et à
l'extérieur des panneaux petite vidéo il
fait ça fait des plaques sont créés si
tu as des amis désolé tus commencé en
faisant mal aux oreilles ça peut aller
très vite
on peut très vite dégénérer t'as quoi
qu'est-ce qu'il a tourné chez un poids
depuis ces merdes à tapas préparées que
j'ai un acouphène t'es sérieux
oui bon on est là pour quoi on pourrait
parler comme ça pendant des heures j'ai
gagné grâce à lui que nous sommes réunis
aujourd'hui pourquoi parce que vous êtes
tous les deux sur youtube depuis très
très très longtemps et vous connaissez
donc d'aider mondial des choses très
ancienne du game non mais on te voit
présentant le bruit va voter vraiment
visible j'ai donc vous êtes sur youtube
depuis très longtemps jonathan faut que
ces fous [ __ ] vous remettez au tout
début
l'intro
[Musique]
à ma gauche après c'est un truc idiot 2
minutes 30 je vais enfin introduire le
sujet tu as voulu me couper sinon
j'allais dire c'est drôle de mettre un
petit extrait de la fin on a à bientôt
merci beaucoup les amis c'était sympa
les gars je peux réussir à introduire on
se dit ok je contextualise et j'étais
assez longtemps
maxence nous met la pression parce que
doit partir dans vraiment dans le 25
minutes du coup le tourner avec un gars
qui te dit je parle 35 minutes la vasque
en 3g prévue à 16h et qu'au final à 17
ans alors peux tu expliquer pourquoi il
a commencé voilà un nom et des chats
alors
[Applaudissements]
oui
les garder sur youtube depuis très
longtemps oui on s'est connus sur
plouffe sable venait de le noter plouffe
2002 13 tu sais où on s'est connu est le
cas pour quid de cyprien ben on a fait
du bruit non non c'est un faux ni après
bref on est là depuis très longtemps on
connaît des vieux vieux truc de youtube
et surtout c'est pas juste on a connu
tout ça c'est qu'on est passionné par sa
aujourd'hui on va faire une crise comme
ce qu'on avait fait à l'époque justement
avec cyprien c'est exact même chose
c'est un quiz sur youtube il ya seize
questions est ce que vous appelez on va
compter les points vous donner tout une
manière de compter les points originales
sont plus on y va tranquille
il ya des gommettes on se coltine de
mettre son front tu parle de trucs de la
vie des origamis les yeux sa vie oui je
les aurais tu as vidéo d'ailleurs est
celui qui gagne a le droit de faire
pendant 20 secondes toute la promo qui
bloquait genre le monde paie qui est
sorti gagnant
les questions sous forme de qcm ray pour
ce numéro une deux trois quatre
on montrera donc en même temps un
chiffre et que nos doigts pour dire moi
je file à la pause 3 etc
si vous et incomprise par garde en 5
secondes vous allez comprendre question
numéro et que nous y allons maxence eu
l'oeil laquelle de ces vignettes de
l'ama fâché n'existe pas c'est la
dernière fois que tu lis une question
avant les dix plus grands chefs du monde
cette feuille de fous ces sifflets 4 un
peu les deux races de chevaux les plus
incroyables du monde
la proportion troubles les dix plus
grands requins du monde
les dix plus grands animaux de la ferme
du monde entier ok vous avez tout dans
votre tête oui j'ai connu ce cas toile
qui augmente avec les doigts la réponse
qu'on france est aveugle
c'est bob 1 2 3 j'ai vu les autres c'est
pour toi c'est les deux races de chevaux
les besoins du monde mais on s'en fout
du titre tu penses que cette idée hâtif
actrice je pense que le puits à
fontjoncouse bien là bas comme un bras
lors il est assez vicieux pour faire une
fausse miniature tu vois un peu trop
moi je mangeais pas payé assez pour
qu'ils passent plus de temps et je suis
ok on y va réponse on va si je suis donc
content tu vois trop compliqué pour
garnir toqué youtube heureuse n'existe
pas youtube heureuse c'est quelqu'un que
théo le zozo victoria la fofolle anthony
le foufou yo yo la tengo attend il y en
a qu'un qui n'existe pas ouais c'est ça
qui paraît fou pour moi c'est bizarre
qui est deux fois et fofolle et
foncièrement la version féminin tu as et
pour moi j'ai ma réponse dans ce café
trop gag je trouve à mon goût du viol
d'un bon c'est pas eu lieu dans ce jeu
vous êtes prêts oui à 1 2 3 ah ouais
hein
ouais ouais nous le zozo existe mais qui
si sûr quand on ne jurerait pas ou bien
la réponse band de saint jacques avec 3
lequel de ces titres de vidéos de race
mot n'existe pas donc c'est des vrais
miniature célébrer miniature mais il ya
un titre qu'il faut hockey covoiturage
en audi r8
on quitte un seul fil existant dans ce
trou ça je lui fais manger un cactus ils
vont aux urgences puis ça c'est vrai ça
je pense c'est vrai de covoiturage en
père noël on s'embrouille avec le
chauffeur vendre à un humain sur le bon
coin on brouille qui a acheté ce que ce
sont les clients du bon je vais acheter
arrive à ses fins manège région que lost
un humain tuerie pas trop avec eux les
gars n'oubliez pas les quatre miniatures
sont vraies mais il ya un titre qui ment
sur le propos de la vidéo
ok vous êtes près 1 2 3 j'ai oublié à 1
et 3
toi qui dit roy c'est pourquoi parce que
le mec à droite en orange c'est
clairement pas le chauffeur de la
voiture
c'est quoi ça groupe s'il ya eu une
embrouille il ya soit un fils qui vient
soit un gendarme
il n'y a pas un mec avec un [ __ ] de
gilet orange et ça n'a pas de sens et le
float il le faut comme si c'était lui le
show va aller je peux dire quelles
activités thibault etienne n'at-il
jamais réalise
merci fabriquer sa propre cotées ou non
je trouvais ça j'ai envie d'avoir envie
de piquer vendeur chez micromania
ok j'ai un bout de chou devenir aveugle
sa gelée vu les jurés à doha qat
retourner avec jacques et michel sage
les vieux aussi êtes prêts oui et quand
je veux dire le mot cassoulet on va
montrer le chiffre avec nos doigts
cassoulet attendant la réponse oui qui
n'a pas réalisé de vidéos instagram
contrôle benoît s'agit aussi sur le mavi
j'ai une faiblesse sur nokia stores met
je ne connais pas et vous moi je
connaissais pas de murs de nîmes
c'est une meuf de montpellier à
montpellier birdy brias la miniature
alors enjoy 100% de la fête vous
garantissant la fête sur à west ham sur
le raptor europe tout comme ça tout
humour chicros allez vous êtes prêt à
2,3 ego hockey attention évidemment il
s'y trouvait la suite de la vidéo pas
bon mais tout va se fracasser le crâne
contre son bureau les chauves a été revu
de façon très violente mais tout va
vomir mais où va muer voilà juste ça ok
je pense que j'ai dans mon cas je pense
j'ai l'impression de l'avoir vu ce truc
pas c'est bon les gars et les deux
premières c'est sûr on est d'accord
we had trois réponses j'espère que c'est
là une lacune c'est se fracasser le
crâne elle à 2 c est ternie de façon
très violente
ok on va on regarde
ces bijoux et michou alors qu'on pense
qu'ils auront fait une fracture du crâne
et sur sept les gares aux quais quel est
le titre de la vidéo de terek en irak on
y voit là je n'ai pas on peut faire un
petit brief sur qui tu arrives cetim
quelqu'un qui s'appelle tara qui est une
personne dans la réalité il n'est pas
virtuel
d'accord ça c'est la miniature on a
quatre proposés se trouvait tic je vois
la boisson du film poursuit panda est en
vrai avec le fou ça tourne mal
arrosez les raquettes avec de la pisse
certains omg je tente devant d'une
boisson sur le bon coin c'est un mec
quoi que ce soit c'est pas moi je vois
trois passes et je clique way for night
en vrai je vois pas du tout le rapport à
6 genre la beurette seraient les propos
de schild et à droite
ok ça se trouve c'est le premier je vole
la boisson du fou est en fait c'est il a
créé un mec ça va le fou ça buzz et
j'aurais pas dû récemment sont
politiquement c'est ça ok vous êtes près
les gars 3 2 1
[Musique]
oui il est prêt à croiser des racailles
avec de l'abysse en fait son visage
c'est un emoji pas compte en gros ce
recueil ces racailles ou aidera cacho
une planche en bois avec laquelle de ces
vidéos clown tueur n'existe pas ah oui
une grosse mandale pots de peinture
anniversaire du cloud tueur ça tourne
mal
inculture commando mcdonald's drive with
what the fuck je vole la voiture du clan
tuera tous turquie n'a pas d'enfant 8
ans vous êtes prête un deux trois ok a
dit roy jeudi 3 3 c'est quoi ces oies
deux fois que je veux la voiture du
tueur fallait dire celui qui existe pas
tu veux qu'on fasse semblant hockey est
bonne on attend sa soute a quand même
bon c'est ce qui serait bien c'est la
moins crédible mais c'est fou ok
question 1 quel est le titre de la vidéo
mais c'est mort je peux plus c'est mort
c'est trop encore la vidéo elle va
démonétisé mais moi quand je paie la
note
alors si tu veux on décrit vite fait tu
le foot ok en gros c'est une femme
allongée sur son lit et il ya peu de
sens on suppose qu'elle a ses règles
c'est très mal et non comme un jeu qu'il
ya eu un mort à côté
non mais c'est abusé alors c'est un but
franck avoir ses règles avec mon petit
copain prend que je lui fait croire à
une fausse couche prend que je fais
croire à ma copine qu'elle est vierge
quoi prendre gens que je me laisse ma
copine au lit mais rien n'est crédible
cessé dans le but d'en lever le tabou
sur les règles ça c'est génial mais
c'est pas du tout la bonne manière de le
faire oui c'est pas du tout ça c'est pas
des rats prix a le mandat mais là ça
c'est vraiment un couteau mais ça n'a
aucun sens g c'est bon j'ai la réponse
attention je vous expliquais après vous
allez vas-y les frais 1 2 3 gemalto a
lâché 2 3 et 4
ok personne ne gagne c'est fou on en a
10 3 sur 4 quelle vidéo de mrg piste
n'existe pas j'ai acheté une voiture
avec des pièces de un centime ah oui il
fait ça lui tout en s'assurant offrir
trois millions deux cents âmes trois
millionième abonné au fait quatre
millions de cook et avons quatre
millionième abonné c'est chiant offrir 6
millions pringles aman 6 millionième
abonné il y en a une qui l'a pas fait je
pense que j'ai 1 2 3 et 4
ok 4-4-3 donc nous on est pour les
pringles et toi tu es pour les cookies
attention intense
[Musique]
c'est fou quoi tintin de calibrage donc
à dire tout en question c'est bientôt
fini
quel youtuber animal il n'existe pas
l'ours enragé loutre en colère
phacochères volant hyper énerve
en tout cas c'est que des gens énervés
du coup il y en a un qui veulent juste
celui du coup vous n'êtes rien et de et
toi ego de droit mais la loutre pour moi
c'est trop à la mode
oualalou moissac existence en cause non
seulement phacochères aussi pour moi
c'est une bree privé job je pensais
faire la peau de loup 103 la mode l'ours
boss trop basique pour servette a dit
père s'appelait de la vie perso je suis
réservé et yes yes yes
alors faites des chaînes outre en
couleur et c'est la question 2 quel est
le titre de cette vidéo de monsieur
faucon le manège se détache et tombe sur
une voiture elle fait un malaise dans la
catapulte manège disposition ses tombés
de la montagne russe elle confie un
horrible secret en plein vol moi je sais
que ça fait longtemps
elle confirme horrible secret au plafond
ok vous avez les réponses mais 1 2 3 go
[Musique]
je l'attends saintonge légal et regarde
la dernière fois que ce genre va parler
à chiquer s'est élevé
[Applaudissements]
moi j'arrête de rien je vais pulvériser
il fait peur ne méprisez jamais ça vous
fait [ __ ] dire avec quelle vidéo story
tarim de tanins bonjour n'existe pas
star disney me vole de l'argent pour de
la cocaïne
ben déjà déjà c'est sûr elles n'existent
plus parce qu'il a dû la faire supprimer
à se donner mon rendez-vous thindwa
failli me tuer j'ai vomi sur quelqu'un
dans un restaurant cinq étoiles
j'ai été arrêté et banni de londres tous
en une semaine mais a quand même 3 par
mesa qu'existent les fous le rdv thunder
qui a fait le tuer je trouve ça trop
source de bosses et trous gré du bst au
lieu de rendez-vous qui tombe mal c'est
les gens sont rouvrir a dû le faire
vomir sur 15 arrêts soit 5 étoiles
facile à faire pourquoi pas arrêter
banni de londres c'est tellement extrême
que j'y crois pour moi c'est disney on y
va à 2 et 3 égaux vous avez pris 3 mais
chaque chose que je dois info des amis à
rodez la question avec maxim maksimov
unis c'est la phrase de ce tout nouveau
youtube heures c'est une méconnaissance
lisez les amis je suis super impatient
et excité voilà ma chaîne youtube va
sortir très bientôt la première chaîne
mes amis vous avez une idée je suis moi
je pense que max on s'est concerté je te
le diront provient d'ailleurs la
première chaîne youtube octobre
utah la première chaîne but de france la
vérité à l'eau abbas était youtube de
france à la véritable dommages du moc
est démolie et c'est là ça nous amène à
la dernière question de squeeze là non
pas de ce quiz il y est sympa fallait
d'affaires au monde où venir même si
calme et exceptionnel tu vas voir
gagnent vs n'at-il jamais goûté de la
bière au vagin une mégane une salade à
155 euros le burger dit brad et moi j'ai
ma réponse
voilà je de tenter un truc je suis
tantôt 1 2 3 et gore oh la la
ah on est tous les deux avant le 4 c'est
vrai que je prends
[Musique]
chacun 4
sainte attendez attendez c'était prenez
chacun une échoppe les amis c'est
l'heure de vérité
je suis à 5,7 en moyenne égalité yens
égalisent 1 comment on fait on n'a qu'à
partager les 10 secondes chacun moi
sommes je vais lancer le décompte 3,2 à
gand toi vas-y je commence ma mère
abonnez vous à ma chaîne là je
travaillais sur une très très grosse
vidéo qui va être incroyable elle sort
début août
vous n'êtes pas pris top j'ai sorti mon
enfant qui s'appelle @ est disponible
sur toutes les plateformes de streaming
est allé l'écouter dites moi ce que vous
en pensez et je dois vital à mon rendez
vous dont il est atteint bon les gars je
vais une eau trop rapide parce que
tintin com rendez-vous et toi on pouvait
tourner encore une heure mais bon il
faut bien que ça termine un jour
merci à tous derrière cette vidéo
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à la chaîne
de sa belle-fille de maxence et à passer
écouter loupé de maxent ce lien est en
discussion si vous a su sont obligés
surtout le son l'été qui pour moi le vin
c'est gentil blma moi c'est désert voilà
bientôt merci beaucoup les amis c'était
sympa bisous oui allez tout ça n'est pas
faux
[Musique]